actually just done a small tangent so
how how do you have a productive day do
you have any insights on how to manage
your time optimally yeah I I mean I've
gone the gamut of from obsessive time
tracking in 15 minute buckets to kind of
like the The Other Extreme where it's
more
um
kind of like large scale
some deep work here two-hour bucket you
know account for an hour of lunch and
some other thing but now now I just
roughly because I manage a team and
there's some things that kind of come up
I it's only a team of two it's not like
big but I just have things that are not
necessarily controllable by me I like
have to take some meetings or whatever
it's not as easy to plan out my day
ahead of time so I do a lot of
retrospective time management where I
look at my day and that's what I mostly
do now
um and I account did I spend this day
productively what could I do better and
then try to implement it in the future
so a lot of this I realized is very
personal for me
I do very well in Long streaks of
working and if I I can't do a lot of
work in 15 minutes I can't do a lot of
work in even an hour but if you give me
like three hours or five hours or six
hours of uninterrupted work that's like
that's where I get most of my stuff done
so from the it just it'd be fun to
explore those when you did 15 minute
buckets so you have a day in front of
you yeah and you have like a Google
sheet or a spreadsheet or something yeah
I didn't Excel Excel uh and you're
do you have a plan for the day or do you
go like when you did it uh or you just
literally
sort of focus on a particular task and
then you're tracking as you're doing
that task of every 15 minutes yeah I
would kind of do it live
um I'm not so one of the reasons I'm so
obsessive about it is because I'm not
organized by nature and I lost like in
college I learned how much
lack of organization can just hurt you
in terms of output
and so I realized like I just had to
build systems that would enable me to
become more organized so uh
really I think I think that doing that
really taught me a lot about time in the
same way that tracking calories can
teach you about food yes like just
learning accounting for these things
will give you skills that eventually you
might not need to track on such a
granular level because you've kind of
like figured out so that's kind of how I
feel about it I think everyone should if
you care about productivity and stuff
should do a little bit of it I don't
think it's sustainable in the long term
it just takes so much effort and time to
like and I think the marginal
effect of it in the long term is kind of
minimal once you learn these basic
skills but um
yeah I was basically tracking like live
what I did and what I saw is that a lot
of my real work would be done in small
sections of the day and then it'd be
like a lot of just nothing like a lot of
small things where I'm busy but little
is being achieved and so I think that's
a really interesting Insight I've never
figured out how to unbusy myself and
focus on the like core Essentials I'm
still getting to that but
um it is interesting realizing most of
your day is like a lot of nothing and
then like some real deep work where most
of your value comes from is like 20 of
your day yeah I try to start every day
with that so the hardest task of the day
and you focus for long periods of time
and I also have the segment of two hours
or it's a set of tasks that I do every
single day the idea is you do that for
like your whole life it's like long-term
investment of Anki and it's just like
learning and
um
reminding yourself of facts you know
they're useful in your everyday life and
then for me also music I'll play a
little bit of music piano piano so like
keeping that regular thing is part of
your life and one thing that I've really
taken from this is because I've read all
the like I had a self-improvement phase
in my early 20s
um and one thing you learn is that
everyone wants to give you a broad
General solution
but really the real trick of figuring
out like optimizing is figuring out the
things that work for you specifically so
like one interesting thing you said is
like oh I like to do my hard work at the
beginning of the day
um
I know a lot of people recommend this
I've tried so many times and I just do
better work late at night and so usually
my streak of work is like from like
after dinner 7 30 to like 2 A.M that's
my prime time
um and so like a lot of my videos which
you'll see which is like lit from this
studio which appears to be daytime it's
like shot at 3am you know just like in a
caffeine field Rush
um but that's kind of how it works for
me and then also like with the social
outlets and stuff like that which it's
easy and I know I feel like we think
similarly on this so it's easy to
Discount these things as less relevant
because they don't have quantitative
metrics associated with them
but in terms of longevity and like I
think to be able to do creative work
there's an amount of recharge and like
re-inputting stuff that is frequently
discounted by People Like Us who are
like obsessed with you know quantitative
metrics and so I really found that some
of my best work gets done after I take
like a break or I like I'll I'll go play
like live sets uh of music and I mean
like that's like for me really
recharging but nowhere on a spreadsheet
is that going to show up as productive
or like meaningful but for me
for whatever reason it recharges me in a
way that like I need to pay attention to
yeah for sure I usually have a
spreadsheet a 15-minute increments when
I'm socially interacting with people and
I evaluate how I'm getting roasted right
now no I'm not it's actually I uh
probably roasting myself but I do find
that when I do have social interactions
I like to deal with people that are in
outside of that exceptionally busy
themselves because then you understand
the value of time
and when you understand the value of
time your interaction becomes more
intimate and intense
like the cliche of work hard Party hard
or whatever the cliches play hard damn
it whatever the uh
just kidding
um uh the that I mean that cliche
there's a truth to that but the
intensity of the social interaction
even like you know it's not even the
intensity like it's not even the party
hard it's like um
even if you're going hiking and relaxing
and taking in nature so it's very
relaxed but you understand the value of
that there's when you put a huge amount
of value on those moments spent in
nature that recharges me much more so
you have to surround yourself with
people that think of life that way that
think about the value of every single
moment that's one of the things you do
when you break it up in 15-minute
increments is you realize how much time
there is in the day how much awesomeness
there's in the day to experience to get
done and so on and then so you can feel
that when you're with somebody
um and then for me personally like when
I interact with people I really like to
be fully present for the interaction
like I can tell this is for anyone who
had you know I've been the audience
forever so I I haven't been on the side
of the table before you're very intense
you look right in the eye I don't know
about writing the eye eye contact is an
issue but yes Alexa is a Soulful gaze
guys just in case you're wondering yeah
it's very Soulful all right all right
back to serious talk okay